Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We've seen a lot of fluid and smoke simulations
throughout the series.
In each of these cases, the objective was
to maximize the realism of these animations,
often to the point where they are indistinguishable
from reality.
However, there are cases where creating photorealistic
footage is not the main objective.
Artists often seek to imbue these fluid and
smoke simulations with their own distinctive
style, and this style needs not to be photorealistic.
It can be cartoonish, black and white, or
take a variety of different color schemes.
But unfortunately, to obtain such an effect,
we have to sit down, get a bunch of papers,
and draw the entirety of the animation frame
by frame.
And of course, to accomplish this, we also
need to be physicists and know the underlying
laws of fluid dynamics.
That's not only borderline impossible, but
extremely laborious as well.
It would be really cool to have an algorithm
that is somehow able to learn our art style
and apply it to a fluid or smoke simulation
sequence.
But the question is, how do we exactly specify
this style?
Have a look at this really cool technique,
I love the idea behind it: first we compute
a classical smoke simulation, then, we freeze
a few frames and get the artist to colorize
them.
After that, the algorithm tries to propagate
this artistic style to the entirety of the
sequence.
Intuitively, this is artistic style transfer
for fluid animations, but, without using any
machine learning techniques.
Here, we are doing patch-based regenerative
morphing.
This awesome term refers to a technique that
is trying to understand the direction of flows
and advect the colored regions according to
it in a way that is both visually and temporally
coherent.
Visually coherent means that it looks as close
to plausible as we can make it, and temporally
coherent means that we're not looking only
at one frame, but a sequence of frames, and
the movement through these neighboring frames
has to be smooth and consistent.
These animation sequences were created from
8 to 9 colorized frames, and whatever you
see happening in between was filled in by
the algorithm.
And again, we're talking about the artistic
style here, not the simulation itself.
A fine, handcrafted work in the world dominated
by advanced learning algorithms.
This paper is a bit like a beautiful handmade
automatic timepiece in the era of quartz watches.
If you enjoyed this episode, please make sure
to leave a like on the video, and don't forget
to subscribe to get a glimpse of the future
on the channel, twice a week.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!